同学们晚上好啊。
现在开始上课，好久没有晚上录课了，是吧？
很久很久没有晚上录课了，现在是晚上啊，我跟你说晚上录课有个什么区别啊？
晚上啊。
人的。
嗓音打开了。
你看他们歌手录歌啊，都是晚上录，因为人啊经经过这一天啊，嗓音才完全打开。你看我现在嗓音就打开了。
各位亲爱的听众朋友，大家晚上好，欢迎来到查理的编剧课是吧？反应打开了，但是缺点是什么？你知道吗？
缺点是脑子有点不太清楚，刚才对于看着有点精神混乱是吧？有点精神错乱。对，因为人啊上了一定年纪之后啊，你不可能全天保持高度的注意力集中。
精神最好的时候啊，其实就是早上和上午。
就是上午这个时段，早上这个时段精神最好。所以之前的课我们基本上都是选择上午录是吧？选择这个精神比较饱满的时候。
有利有弊吧，对吧？咱们任何事情都要扬长避短吧，不扯淡了。好吧，今天晚上呢给大家录一节课，为啥晚上赶紧录一课呢？因为最近有个片子啊特别火，很多同学强烈要求我讲一讲啥片子呢？很多同学都知道啊。
游鱼游喜。
我说鱿鱼游戏这个剧啊，最近可真是太火了。
火出圈了。
是吧。
我看新闻说是在什么北美呀、澳洲呀，然后在欧洲呀，全都登顶了那个电视剧收视率的榜首，霸榜了。然后全球主流的那些大综艺，对吧？那些戏大戏都邀请这些演员邀请这些主创去参加。
这个情况其实很少见啊。
为啥呢？因为说到底，这是一个。
东亚的剧。
咱们因为是上课啊，没有外人，咱们关起门来说，从学术角度啊，我们东亚呀咱们东亚呀在这个文化输出上啊一时处于。
略越世地位。
对吧剧呢就更劣势了，那肯定是很劣势呀。咱们的剧的输出啊，基本上就是东亚，咱们范围内自己自己窝里横，对吧？韩国的剧确实强，由于游戏就是韩国的啊，网飞跟韩国一起做的。
韩国的剧呢虽然强，但也是窝里横，对吧？像全亚洲输出韩流，对吧？这个这个这个这个各种偶像，各种这这种那叫什么？
练习生偶像。
idol对吧？这种文化是他们输出。你像日本呢影视剧有时候也挺强的，也但也基本上在咱亚洲范围内。
晃悠对吧？这严格说就是在咱东亚晃悠，西亚都不看。然后呢，咱们中国呢也有输出的，咱们一般输出点啥啊？
武侠剧和修仙剧，因为这些玩意儿吧，他们其他地方不拍，不会弄。咱们呢也输出一下这个这个这个在东亚范围内，对吧？就像我们以前拍戏，经常可以卖给泰国呀、越南呀、柬埔寨呀、老挝呀这些国家。
嗯，当然这几年还有个趋势啊，你像修仙类啊，这个这个这个武侠类啊，还可以卖给非洲，可能与这个一带一路有关系哈，就是中国跟非洲的关系啊，就是那些黑人。
兄弟看我们的武打片，看我们的那种古装仙侠片也在那嗷嗷的哭啊，也有这个趋势啊。
但总体来说啊，东亚的这个剧啊，一般就在东亚咱们自己范围内消化。就是咱们黄种人啊自己跟黄种人自己玩。
但是像这次这个游鱼游戏这么出圈呢，在剧的这个。
在聚集方面啊确实比较少见比较少见。
所以今天呢咱们就讲一讲这个犹鱼游戏，好吧，讲一讲这个犹鱼游戏。很多同学也问。
首先咱们先定个信啊，游于游戏肯定是个好片子啊。
肯定是个好片子，这个这个这个毋庸置疑毋庸置疑。
但是咱们都是搞创作的啊，咱们就从创作角度去去去研究这个片子。今天照例啊不是拉片，不是拉片儿，我可以给你简单讲一下剧情，不涉及剧透，给你讲一下结构，对吧？因为这个片子的结构啊没有什么出奇的。很多同学一目了然就知道他大概讲什么故事。所以我可以给大家讲一讲啊。
但不是拉片，我们还是力求从这个片子当中那学到我们需要学的东西，好吧。
首先这个片子大概讲什么故事啊，我们可以先简单描述一下，就是一群欠债的人，一群穷人被人捉了起来，关在一个密闭空间里被逼做游戏。这个游戏呢输了得死。
真死啊当场死亡，血淋淋的。
赢了呢，最后只有一个赢家，赢者通杀，赢者全拿，赢得400多亿。
裁员反正就是非常大的一笔钱。
因为参加这个游戏的人呢都是群穷人，走投无路的人，所以这个钱呢诱惑力格外的大，包括对我们的男主。
我也算他双男主吧啊，这个这个吸引力特别大。然后呢，结局就是。
这个过程呢就是这群人不断的玩游戏，人越来越少，都死掉了。最后剩下了我们的两个男主，然后决一死战，其中一个人胜出了。
就是这么个故事。
熟悉创作的同学啊。
或者是同事创作的同学，或者是阅偏量很大的同学都会觉得咦这个故事好像似曾相识嘛，对吧？好像我们看过很多这样的故事，确实啊。
这个故事啊在我们以往的创作中，我们甚至都它都算一个类型。
都算一个就把一群人关起来做游戏，然后奖励和惩罚奖励很诱惑，惩罚很残酷，规则很简单。
关起来做游戏这种片儿吧。
他没有严格的故事类型，一个明朝啊，没有没有这个学术上的一个名号。我们私底下一般管这这类片子叫大逃杀模式。
因为大逃杀就是这种剧情嘛，对吧？然后嘞也比较典型。
我们一般管这种模式叫大淘杀模式。
或者叫他游戏模式吧，我们打眼一想就能想到很多片子是这样的，除了游于游戏，还有啥？
我们说。
那个那个雪国列车。
是吧然后。
这个这个这个电锯惊魂。
那关起门来做游戏啊。
输了得死啊。
还有什么死亡飞车。
死亡游戏。
还有什么。
赌博启示录，哎，咱们也翻拍了一版赌博启示录，李易峰的叫动物世界剪刀石头布嘛？最后赢者全拿嘛，对吧？
很多啊很多这种类型的故事一下就能想起来，就是把一群人关起来，逼他们做游戏啊，还有一个也一模一样的弥留之际的爱丽丝，对吧？也是赌博嘛。
其实啊严格来说啊，西部世界也算。
关起门来做游戏嘛，对吧？西部是也严格来说也算。所以说这所以说啊我们就发现啊由于游戏这个故事啊好像不是那么新颖嘛。
是为什么嘞？对吧？这个故事这个类型好像一直有嘛。
今天我们就来。
研究一下这个问题。
首先我们先明确一个立场啊，游于游戏拍的非常好。
完成度很高。
然后。
虽然说这个故事类型啊不是特别新。
我们说韩光韩国就拍过很多个版本。
这种类型的故事。
因为。
韩国比较喜欢这个类型。
我们先说一下这个这个类型里面它有些什么东西啊，首先啊他肯定说的是你看啊一群穷富人在玩弄穷人嘛。
玩弄求人取乐了，这个比喻啊并不新鲜。
对吧他其实比喻的是这个阶层呀。
贫富差距呀这些东西对吧？
这个这个这个我们说这个东西啊，在韩国啊比较容易形成。
共鸣。
和这个这个这个。
韩国喜欢这个东西，韩国人喜欢这个调调。
他们的那个哎，还有韩国的得奖的那个韩国得奥斯卡的那个。
寄生虫。
寄生虫不也是讲了这个阶层呀、贫富呀，你看韩国人特别喜欢探讨这个东西，对吧？他们对这个东西比较敏感，比较有共鸣。当然一方面是因为韩国的贫富差距确实挺大的。
更重要的是什么啊？因为韩国呀。
就说。
韩国处于一个。
东西方交汇的很拧巴的一个处境。
这么说吧，首先啊韩国的文化底层是东方逻辑。你看啊韩国人比我们更尊师重道，更尊重前辈，尊重长辈，甚至韩国岁数压你一点的人，你对他得说敬语。
他对你说评语。
对吧然后呢，他甚至可以骂你。
你跟他倒酒和他跟你喝酒，这个规矩大了。
我有很多韩国朋友岁数比我小的那些跟我喝酒，我都觉得。
哎呀对吧？很奇怪，你知道吧？他喝酒他都要拧过头去，因为你是哥哥。
就他们的规矩大了，更不用说你看韩国那种。
上司欺负后辈，潜规则下属那个那个那个他这个这个。
这个长又有序，这个这个这个我们说这个东西吧，是咱们东方的文化。
咱们的东方文化比较讲究这个就是这个这个这个长辈呀、前辈呀，我们比较讲究这个对吧？然后韩国的这个东西，它东方的这套东西它继承的很。
很很很完整，很坚持。
然后呢，我们说韩国又是彻头彻尾的西方。
那套正体。
也就是他在软件上呢，他又他又操作系统上呢，他又装了西方那一套东西。
就导致吧。
有一种说法啊说韩国融合了东西方的糟粕。
有一种说法是这么说啊，他融合了东西方的糟粕，他把两边的不好的地方都给拿走了，然后很拧吧，形成了他的这些人吧。
阶级固化，然后贫富差距，导致他们很敏感。这个事情，这是一种说法啊。所以你看韩国出了很多这种片子，不管是寄生虫啊，还是雪国列车呀，还是游鱼游戏啊，这些就这这几部片子是韩国享誉全球的吧，对吧？享誉全球的片子，全是探讨这个问题的。
这与他们的文化背景有关系啊，这个是插一句。我们说回这个游鱼游戏这种类型啊，我们说它叫游戏类。我们之前叫它大淘杀类，对吧？
我们现在可以把它定义为游戏类，它是一个题材啊。
同学们，这个分类方式，我们不要去把它跟金羊毛那套分类方式搞混了啊。
这是另外一种分类思维嗯。
对，我们算他选财思维吧，因为。
救猫咪那套类型啊，它是故事类型，它是讲故事的类型。而游戏类的这种选题呢，它是一种选材类型，或者是一种构建世界观的类型。我们这么去理解这个问题，好吧，所以我们把它理解为说这种游戏类，我们暂且叫它这个名字啊。
游戏类的这类故事。
我们说他有些什么样的特性？
它有些什么样的特性？我们借由。
这些片子我们总结一下，首先啊游戏类的片子它都有一个空间。
他都有个相对封闭的空间，让这些参与者跑不了。
对吧然后他有了空间之后呢，他就要有来参与的人。
参与人呢基本上分成两种，一种是。
庄稼。
一种是玩家。
对吧。
分成这两部分。然后呢，有空间，有了参与人之后呢，他会有个规则。
有个规则，就说这群人在在玩啥？
他得有个规矩啊。
我们怎么玩，玩了之后会怎样？能有个规矩，对吧？那有这个规则之后呢。
他就会有带来奖励。
讲咋写？
奖励和惩罚。
我们说这个奖励往往非常诱人，这个惩罚呢。
也通常非常吓人，比如说死亡，由于游戏里面就是赤裸裸的死亡呀，大部分这类游戏里面都是死亡，惩罚都是死亡。
我们来着重说一下。
这个东西规则这个东西。
这类游这类游戏类的这个选题。这类选题的。
影片。
他最重要的就是个规则。
它的规则往往是什么呢？
他的规则往往是。
社会。
真实规则的一种。
担忧。
或者一种放大。
或者我们统称为社会。
规则当中的一个比喻吧。
比如我们说由于游戏也好。
还是这个这个这个赌博骑示录也好，还是这个雪国列车也好，他基本上都是在说。
阶层固化的事情，贫放贫富差距的事情，对吧？
他是一种。
我们说贫富差距啊、阶层固化呀，社会上确实有。
但没有到这个程度。
对吧这就是一种比喻。而，那个我们中国的那个作家刘慈欣也很喜欢搞这一个调调。
北京折叠就是讲社会固基层固话嘛。
刘慈欣有一个叫赡养人类。
讲贫富差距，讲的更极端，世界上财富全部集中在一个人手里，那个人叫中产者，对吧？讲贫富差距。我们说这种规则。
他往往就是对社会规则的一种担忧。
还有什么规则？
我们说大逃杀啊，他其实讲的是。
教育对人类的分类。
淘汰这样一种比喻。
对吧我们说教育把人这种分成369等进行选材和淘汰，那是这样一种比喻。
啊，很典型的还有啊楚门的世界。
咱们课上讲过吧，楚门的世界不也是密闭空间里面做游戏吗？
严格来说，楚门的世界不也是密闭的空间里面做游戏吗？
密闭的空间做游戏啊。
他比喻的是什么呢？他比喻的是在。
媒体和舆论的控制下，人已经没有。
自己的空间了。
他是做这个比喻的，我说他永远是社会的比喻嘛。
这类影片啊，它永远是社会的比喻。
我们说呃刚才说到这个媒体和舆论让人没有空间。我们还想起来一个片子。
有个片子叫疑犯追踪。
是一个美剧啊，疑犯追踪挺好看的，大家可以去看一下。
那个片子讲的是在大数据有一个天眼。
就是有个东西叫天眼。
也其实就是大数据，在大数据的监视下，每个人毫无隐私，而且哪些人会犯罪，他其实能算出来。
就哪些人有能犯罪，他其实能算出来。在天眼下，每个人毫无隐私。
然后那个片子就够是用的这个。
规则用了这个比喻。我们说。
这类游戏类的片子啊。
往往你先设计一个空间，然后设设计一下参与的人，然后最重要的是制定这个规则。然后基于这个规则会产生奖励和惩罚。
这就是我今天最主要想跟大家说的，就是游戏类的这类片子啊，我们其实见过挺多的啦。
它并不新鲜。
当然，由于由于游戏它的完成度很高，而且他演员演的也特别好啊。
人家成本也很高，耗资也非常大，拍的确实是不掉链子，导致了人家成为了爆款。
然后呢，我们就借此机会。
学习温习一下这类故事，这其实不是故事类型啊，还是我再强调这是选材类型，其实这是世界观的类型，世界观类型里面一种特殊的游戏类的设定。
然后。
说到这儿啊，我们就来探讨一下一个另外一个问题。
就是哎这个选材为什么这么。
奇怪了。
怎么跟闹着玩似的呢？这个这个电影或者这个剧这个故事。
怎么跟做游戏似的？
怎么跟闹着玩似的，现实生活中也不会发生这样的事情呀，对吧？
这其实就涉及到。
我们今天要讲的另外一个概念啊。
叫做强设定。
这个概念啊这几年经常被提及，就是有一类选材，有一类选题叫强设定。
游戏类显然就属于强设定的一种。
显然属于强色病的一种。
好莱坞这几年越来越多的在提这个事儿。
当然受好莱坞影响，咱们国内最近提的也特别多啊，就市场上现在提这个话的人很多，就是希望这个故事是一个强势电影故事。
我们今天就来探讨一下啥叫强势零悟师。
我跟大家说，在强设定的范畴里面，游戏类都不算最强的，不算太强。
对吧我随便给大家说一类啊，来，那我们从人物设定的角度来讲啊，从人物设定来讲，来从主角的角度设定角度来讲，主角有超能力。
对吧主角有超级技能，那这这显然就是一种强设定嘛，显然是一种非现实的设定嘛。
这个这个这个这个我们说超级英雄类的对吧？技能类的来从对手的角度来讲，来，我的对手是个大怪兽。
对手是个大怪兽。
对手是个鬼。
对吧对手是个外星人，这这这这显然也是一种。
设定方式嘛。
他显然也是一种强势力。
我们说还有啊从时间轴的角度来讲，来穿越它。
穿越回古代啊。
对吧那这显然也是一种强势力。穿越啊不是一种简单类型啊，穿越里面其实有好多啊。
分他么精神穿过去的。
还有精神跟肉体一块儿穿过去的。
精神跟穿过去的太子飞生之际，对吧？他的精神穿到古代了，掉在别人的身体里面，而且是一个男人的精神掉在一个妃子女人的身体里了。
还有呢就是人跟肉体一块穿过去的。
比如说那个寻亲记项少龙。
对吧一个香港特警穿越到秦朝。
成为了一个大将军。
他整个一块过去了，对吧？当然还要带着工具过去了是吧？带着家伙事儿过去的都有。另外还有那种。
灵魂互换吧。
什么西羞羞的铁拳这种也算是穿嘛，精神互穿嘛，穿身体了，对吧？当然现在还有发明了各种穿书的、穿漫画的、穿游戏的。
当然这种大部分是为了过审啊，打了擦边球过审，因为不让穿越了。
他们就说自己穿的是书，穿的是游戏。但其实你明白啊，他就是想穿回古代。
这个我们待会儿再讲穿越它有什么特点啊，我们先都整理一下，还有什么啊？我们说与时间有关的，除了时间穿越以外。
还有时间倒流吗？
本杰明巴顿骑士对吧？这种也属于强设定，还有时间静止嘛。
对不对？还有时间就是那个那个长生不老啊，比如说。
不死法医，哎呀，不死法医特别好看吧。
这个这个这个时间停止了，还有这个我们说时间陷入死循环的。
哇，这个前几年也流行过呀。
土拨鼠日，美国电影土拨鼠日。然后后来还有那个我们说其实。
恐怖游轮也算时间循环，对吧？我们叫一个时间的lo嘛，它就陷入这个lo里面了。
这个这个这个。
出不来了。
对吧。
当然我们刚才说的既循环又穿越的那个那个还有一个。
也算是穿越片里面非常经典的。
蝴蝶效应butterfly大家可以去看一下，那个太牛逼了，阿诗伦cuccher演的对吧？那个拍的太牛了。
我说你看这又是一个打类。
对吧当然了，穿越类还不能不提我们公司的那个夏洛特烦恼呀，对吧？我们公司夏洛特烦恼一战成名。后来马上你看李焕英也不成多让啊，也这这个这穿越类强势定类，对吧？
我们说你看这就是在时间上玩花招的，有各种。
有各种强设力。
这就是我说的强势力。
全社定的片子啊，这几年啊非常的兴盛，非常的凶悍。
非常的主流，这么说吧，但其实啊他以前可不是主流啊。
我们说与强设定对应的啊与强设定对应的啊，其实是现实主义设定。
一般设定或者叫他一般设定不就是现实主义设定吗？
就是正常事件下发生的，我们能够理解的那些事情，对吧？正常的社会规则下发生的那些事情，其实就是现实主义设定，它就是一般设定。那如果一般设定是现实主义设定的话，其实强设定你还可以给他。
换一个名字，我们用一个文学小说里面常用的名词可以叫它魔幻现实主义。
其实所谓的强设定，它就是魔幻现实主义，它拥有一定的魔幻色彩。我们刚才说的这些强设定其实都拥有一定的魔幻色彩。
有神秘力量呀。
但是呢还是我说的，它永远是社会的比喻啊。
它永远是社会的比喻啊，你不能完全超现实呀，你超现实我们看它干嘛呀？
所以他其实是魔幻现实主。
对吧不管是说主角拥有的那些技能，其实都是我们曾经想象过的那些想要的那些技能。它有一定的现实依据的。然后我们说那个对手是僵尸，是鬼，是怪兽，是天外来客外星人，其实都是我们日常恐惧。
害怕发生的事情，它是有现实依据的，懂吗？所以说强设定啊你可以理解为魔幻现实主义。
我们可以这么去理解。
那么现实主义设定和魔幻现实主义设定。
在这几年啊有个明确的趋势，有个明显的趋势，就是现实主义的市场份额正在。
减少。
魔幻现实主义的市场份额正在增加，这是一个趋势啊。
我们就从好莱坞来说啊，我给大家讲一个规律。你看啊好莱坞的片子按制作分啊，分A级片和B级片，对吧？这个大家大概都听过这两个呃这个这个这个名词这个说法。
然后很多同学就。
在理解上啊认为啊。
B级片啊就是沾点黄的，沾点暴力。
沾点不入流或者沾点墙类型，对吧？比如说什么战枪战片，这个恐怖片、色情片，这就叫B记片，很多同学都是这么理解的啊。
就是这个有点。
Y的就是B级片，正经片还是A级片。其实不是啊，同学们我给大家讲一下啊。
A级片B级片是按预算分的。
就好莱坞把这个片子啊。
这个片子如果预预算大制作好，然后呢可以面向更多的大众。这类片子呢就评为A级。
然后预算小的那些片子呢叫B集。但这些预算小的片子，他一样要到电影院跟A级片搏杀，对吧？那他打不过，因为预算小没有大明星，那他咋整呢？他就剑走偏锋，对吧？我正常打打不过你，那我就带点黄的，带点暴力。
或者带点恐怖氛围，带点神秘色彩，带点魔幻。
你看看。
B级片呢往往因为被A级片逼得没招。
他就走点儿。
长设定。
所以很多强势这片子啊早年是B级片。
早年是B纸片。
然后呢。
那些现实主义的题材呢，反而是A级片。比如说一个男的跟一个女的谈恋爱，哇，他反而拿到大预算。
你知道吧？然后请两个大明星，然后来演演绎一段传奇的爱情。
你看这种片子啊，在早年啊，他认为这种片子是更广泛范围内大家能接受的。因为你拍个密室杀人，你感觉好像很多人不愿意看嘛，对吧？就是就评为B级了。
那种现实主义的片子啊反而评为A级。
但是在这几年，至少在好莱坞啊，好莱坞因为是电影工业工业化生产，它很现实的，他用大数据说话，然后他他很现实，他评估一个片子就很现实，现在完全反过来了。
就好莱坞现在的A级片啊都是强势兵，你去看好莱坞现在的大制作啊全是强势兵。
全是强势力。
全是带点儿。
魔幻。
现实主义的设定。
反而两个人要想正经谈个恋爱，或者是想拍个传记片，拍拍谁的一生。这种片子啊只能拿到B级片的预算了。
为啥？
给你钱，你想花哪？
你也没地儿花呀，是这个问题，是因为预算现在越来越大了。
所以。
现在的A级片反而是你看好莱坞的A级片，这几年变形金刚速基对吧？然后这个这个这个我跟你讲，速度激情以前就是B级片，就是B级片标准的BG片起家，拍着拍着拍成了A级片了，你知道吧？然后这种。
IP的是吧？哈利波特呃这个这个这个。
这个这个这个加勒比海盗。
这个这个漫威是吧，这个这个复仇者联盟全都是一水的魔幻现实主义，全都是一水的强射电。
所以这几年的A级片啊，其实反而是强势令片了，这个是我们这节课最需要思考的一个问题。
就是强设定的片子逐渐成为了市场主力了。
我们可以分析其中的原因，对吧？但是呢我们更。
更重要的是啊，因为出现了这种情况，我们应该研究一下强势性的片子怎么玩，还怎么写，以及它跟现实主义的题材有些什么样的区别。好吧，这个是我们主要需要研究的啊。
但是啊还是那句话啊，我没有说现实主义题材就不玩了啊，没有那个意思没有那个意思。
还是可以玩还是可以写，你有还是可以写啊。但这节课我们因为讲优鱼游戏，我们着重说一下强势力。
首先来。
我们可以研究一下强设定。我们先从大面上啊说一下呃强势魔幻现实主义强设定和一般设定有些什么样的优点和缺点，肯定都有优缺点的。因为咱们之前课上不是说过嘛，我们以后都要有个扬长避短的思维啊，有有个扬长避短的思维，不能说啊那强势定就无敌干死一般设定，那你吹牛逼了，对吧？
我不是药神，就是现实主义题材。
人家也牛逼着呢。
而且啊我跟你说啊，现实主义有个什么优势啊，现实主义评分高，真的。
现实主义评分高，你一个超级英雄，你一个僵尸片，你一个鬼片，你拍的再好看，分儿不会太高。
懂吧？因为大家都知道这是个快餐。
嗯嗯啊好像没什么深度，明白这意思吧？但是现实主义题材呢，你看你只要细腻的刻画，它分儿都很高。我说最现实主义啊就设定最一般的就是你们之前经常跟我说的失之愈合。
资之愈合。
我们说魔幻现实主义的片子啊，在市场好卖片，为啥呀？因为你一句话就能震住对方。哎，我给你讲一个故事啊，你看啊这个故事就是把一群人关起来做游戏，谁是谁输的谁死赢了那个得到400亿，你看这一句话就觉得哇，这个故事好像挺劲的，对吧？但失之愈合的片子啊。
就会讲，哎，我给你讲一个就是一个落魄的中年人，周末回家跟他妈吃饭的故事。
啊。
然后呢。
啊，然后你给我点预算呀，我去拍，就这就很难卖掉。你明白这意思吧？
但是你看失之愈合，它往往就是这种故事。
他的设定呢就很现实主义很一般。一般设定啊一般不是那个。
别意词的一般啊，就是很普通的设定。
你看这就是区别。但是普通的设定，你如果能让大家看完，哎，你分就很高是吧？这是个但这是这个这个我们说评分上面优缺点，我们主要不是讲这个，我们主要是讲强设定有个什么样的优势啊，强设定就是上来比较唬人，这是肯定的。
对吧。
上来觉得哇牛逼啊，哦，还有这样的片子哦，牛逼牛逼牛逼，但是呢它的长尾往往比较差，就它的持续力比较差。
往往是这样啊。
我们看一下啊，首先我们说强势病，人家在。
人家好莱坞推崇强色电是推崇什么啊？
其实就是推崇电影。
电影反正就俩三钟头的对吧？我唬住你就完事了呗。
所以你看强势钉在电影当中。
逐渐的崛起。
但是由于这几年，我们说剧啊已经摆脱了以前。
肥皂剧爆米花剧的那个地位，它开始成为。
观众主动收视主动消费的一个。
文化产品，所以他也在追求强剧情，追求强设定，对吧？因为要让观众过瘾，要让观众爽，所以他也不是以前的你侬我侬谈情说爱的那种嘻嘻哈哈的那种剧了。所以说剧这几年也在追求强设定。
你就会发现一个问题。
凡是强设定的剧啊，都拍不了几集。
单季来说也拍不了几集，集数都不长。
由于游戏。
八九级是吧？8级不是9级很短的。
而且我们现在基本上可以预言啊。
最多也就拍到第二季，第三季就基本上就差不多了。而且。
口碑也会急速。
往下走的。
这个很现实啊这个很现实。我们今天就是客观的说啊。
然后。
你看同样的，我们说其实啊前几年有个剧从单从开场来说啊，比游鱼游戏还猛。
西部世界。
西部世界单从他当时这个世界观一出来的时候，其实也就是这个魔幻现实主义的强设定义一出来的时候，其实当时在市场上的那个震撼力啊比现在的鱿鱼游戏都猛。
普及率都高。
然后那个舆论更大。
但是我们说。
西部世界我敢说，当时看完的看完整季的都没有多少人。
更不用说看第二季了。然后第二季他发现没人看之后，迅速就砍掉了。
他自己也做不下去了，对吧？
就是这个问题。
他就是。
持续立场。哎，还有那个我刚才说那个不死法医，同学们回可以看一下，就讲一个法医啊，他他长生不老。
他活了很久了。
然后嘞，这个这个这个他不死，他死不掉，每次死了呢，都又重新复活，对吧？重新那个相当于重生。
就一季老好看了，但就一季对吧？就砍掉了，就是它这种强势定啊。
拍片很猛。
持续力就差，是吧？但是你看啊一般设定的剧啊很多就干个什么十季十一计。因为他一旦捏住你之后啊，他后续好发挥。
对吧他后续好发挥，因为他没有用。
强大的规则制约剧情。
他不需要围绕的那个强大的规则做冲突，做对抗。因为你那个规则越强大，实际上就越具体。
越具体就越窄。
可做的戏就越少。
我们说由鱼游戏为什么在这类戏当中？
今年就脱颖而出了呢。首先当然他级数也不差，他也就敢拍8集9集，对吧？
同时人家真的是完成度挺高的。
因为。
这几个演员啊，首先都是非常好的演员。
演技非常非常在线。然后呢，编剧对人物的刻画对人性的挖掘是非常细腻而且深刻的，这个也都。
做到了才保证了他有持续的攻击性。
但是咱们关起门来说啊，由于游戏在第345这几集的时候，就是在后面那几个重要的反转出来之前。
其实开始有点。
有点乏力了，甚至有当时有整集开始煽情了。
就确实是因为持续这个攻击这个规则呀，用这个规则去吸引人啊，确实是。
乏力了。
这个是没有办法的事情。在这里我们强调一下啊。
我们是编剧学习，我们评价任何一个片子都是客观评价。我们要从里面学到东西。
千万不要出现。
有一种情况啊，我是跟你说，同学们有一种情况啊。
在学习当中是最要不得的。
同学们记得吧？我以前讲课举过教父的例子，教父啊是很多人最喜欢的一个电影。这个我知道的，因为它在影史也基本上排名第一第二嘛，对吧？
然后我在课上呢就有一次说我说教父这个片子啊，因为他也有年头了。70年代啊，教父一是70年代的片子。所以从现在的角度看，从现在的审美去看。
他其实节奏是挺慢的，甚至有点沉闷的。我说过这个话。
但当时就马上带来了很多反弹。
我其实跟同学们说过啊，我说我站出来讲课，因为这是一个公共领域的课。
有很多人骂我，我跟你说，因为教父我就挨了不少骂，有些人直接就开骂说，哇，你连教父都看不懂，那你也水平也就到这儿了，对吧？你也别在这叭叭讲课了。
就是产生了一种这个非常大的抵触情绪。很多人。
这个咱们的同学啊认真学习的同学啊，千万不要有这种想法，这种想法要不得，明白吧？这种想法要不得。
因为所有的事物我们都应该做到去客观评判。
千万不要造神。
对吧不要造神，因为这种情况在我们这个在咱们这个互联网上啊，其实挺严重的。客观说啊，就这种我管这种叫互联网恋物屁啊。
猎物屁是咋回事啊？这种这种猎物屁是咋回事？我觉得其实就是精神空虚。
咱们有很多人啊。
他因为没有。
自己独立的这个这个。
独立的三观吧，对吧？因为三观啊有两个来源。
一种来源呢是有利用系统的信仰，对吧？你说我虽然懂得不多，但我有一套系统的信仰，我接受这套信仰的三观。
这是一种。还有一种呢就是说我这个人呢有自己一套知识体系。我以前说过知识树，对吧？你的思维，你的知识有一棵树是你的。
然后呢，你基于你的这个思维，基于你的逻辑，你会产生你的三观，产生你对事物的基本判断。
这样的话你也会有一个。
这个这个比较稳定的逻辑和比较稳定的思维判断。
但是呢咱们有很多朋友啊。
这俩玩意儿他都没用。
他既没有什么系统的信仰。
然后呢，也没有什么自己的一套。
思维体系没有自己的一个逻辑体系。
就导致他呢这个。
他这个这个这个他的思想啊。
游离在这个浩瀚的信息流当中。
那这没有地儿附着肯定不行啊，所以他就附着在比较具体的人或事物上。
然后呢。
就会坚信这个东西。
我管他叫练物癖嘛，对吧？比如说他就会附着在教父上，任何人只要说教父一点一丁点不好，他就马上跳起来，你是傻逼吧，对吧？你这吧？懂不懂啊，就产生了一种这个这个。
这个很极端的这种一种。
一种情绪对吧？就像那个也还有的附着在人身上，是吧？比如说附责在蔡徐坤身上是吧？你就不他他的价值就会变成任何对蔡徐坤有利的都是对的任何。
说坤坤不好的，或者问坤坤唱过什么歌啊，就都是坏人，对吧？就是全是坏蛋。
这个这个这个要不得啊，我们还是要客观的评价，对吧？不管是教父还是坤坤，都有他的优点和缺点。因为它是一个客观的一个事物嘛，对吧？
这个同学们一定要有这个思维啊，不要去有猎物癖。
因为这个情况。
我经常拿汽车举例子啊，就是讲我们的课程，或者是讲我们的编辑知识。我经常用汽车举例子，你看啊这个这个这个。
我们说来。
奔驰好不好？奔驰当然是好车嘛，那这是很好的车嘛。但我们可不可以客观的说一句，奔驰的内饰豪华感比其他车强，但是动力和操控不如宝马，我们可不可以这么说呢？
当然可以嘛。
但这不叫批评奔驰，懂吗？只是客观的从我们假设我们在学习制造汽车，从这个学习的角度，我们客观的去研究一下人家为什么会这样，对吧？他当然是从成本的角度考虑，或者是从综合方面的角度考虑，或者他认为这个这个这个。
操控和动力没有那么重要，对吧？但是你如果在这儿专注操控和动力这个领域，那你可不可以说它奔驰它就是不如。
挖完了。
是不是隔以这么说吧，对吧？就是大家要客观，不要成为这个这个马上就有人跳出来，你买得起奔驰吗？你开过奔驰吗？你懂个屁没有这个必要，不要恋悟，对吧？不要这么迷恋这个事情，好吧？所以咱们这个意思就是什么呢？就客观的说。
游于游戏牛不牛逼，牛逼当然牛逼，咱先承认他牛逼，但是能不能说有缺陷，当然可以说，因为它是这种类型这种大类的缺陷，懂吗？这种大类的缺陷，那知道有缺陷，我们才能扬长避短嘛，才能想办法去弥补啊，是这个意思，明白吧？
好啊，那咱们接着说来。
我们说强势定的片子啊在这几年越来越往上走。
那我们其实就应该重视这个问题。
重视这个问题。
那我们就知道强制定它的优势。
吸引人的眼球。
对抗比较明确，对吧？然后爽点很突出。
缺点呢是爽点容易很快枯解，观众容易产生审美疲劳，然后持续性不佳。
对吧这是优点很明确。但是呢我们又说所有的强设令，因为它脱离一定程度脱离了现实主义，但它必须是魔幻现实主义，它必须是对社会的一种比喻，或者是对人类共同。
期待世欲的一种在人类共同期待事域中一种共同的担忧。
或者是期待，因为还有正面的嘛，不仅是担忧啊，还有正面的。比如说主角。
这个这个这个会飞主角他妈的能隐身，这是这这这就是人类共同的期待嘛，对吧？
那既然是。
需要有这个要求。那么其实还有这种强设定里面，我们还要注意一个事项，就是你这个规则的设定。
他需要符合。
一般预期。
不能太奇怪。
不能太费解，至少对吧？大家都不理解你为什么要设成这么个规则，那就没意思了。我们说你看规则设定里面比较出彩的。
时间规划局。
啊，大家去看一看这个片子啊，叫时间规划局。哇，这个设定太牛逼了。
每个人身上有一只手表。
然后显示你还能活多久。
穷人的手表上永远不超过一天，他需要每天不断的劳作，换取自己的生存时间。所以他身上的时间永远不超过一天，因为被压榨到极限了，每个人能活多久显示在这里。然后那些富人阶层呢，每个人的手上都是9999年满了都。
爆了都永生不死，为什么？因为他可以剥削穷人，压榨穷人，然后穷人天天保着自己这。
24小时。
不到24小时的一个时间，每天不敢有任何一天休息。
他如果生病了不能上班，那他就等于死了。
他上班迟到了，错过。
那个那个公共汽车了，他就死了。
就这么残酷。然后他如果被偷被抢被骗。
他这个时间就被人拿走了。
就是这么残酷，时间规划局，大家去看一下，那个就是对于社会的一种比喻。这种比喻它就很创新，对吧？所以。
我们大家要学会。
这种片子。
它的几个要点，好吧。
我们说扬长避短，再说一遍啊，优点是。
眼前一亮，对吧？爽点明确很抓人眼球，缺点呢是持续性不佳，这个爽点容易枯竭，对吧？特点呢是需要是社会的比喻。
需要有现实意义，因为它是魔幻主义，魔幻现实主义它还是要有现实意义的。
那我们就来看所有的强设定里面。
我们说。
我们的要点是什么？
我们说主角技能类的那就是他这个超能力需要是人类共同的向下。
符合人类的预期，对吧？这个题我们以前训练过吧。
我经常让你们做一个题，我说想象一下你现在可以拥有一个超能力，你要啥，对吧？大家记得过记得做过这样的练习，没做过的回去补一补啊。然后我们说来对手类的，我们说怪兽。
僵尸外星人对吧？这些必须是什么啊？
你不能生造一个啊。
你不能深造一个东西，你说哎呀，我造的这个东西老厉害了。
他不符合我们。
现有的。
预期是不行的。
我给大家讲一个数据啊，网上所有的怪兽票房全部加起来，数据最好的是蛇。
为什么？
是因为全世界的人都怕蛇。
明白吧？所以蛇的数据是最好的。
这就是符合。
我们大家共同，我们本来就怕蛇，你他妈造一个蛇三十几米长，那我更害怕呀。所以数据最好的是蛇，然后这是怪兽片。然后灵异类的呢，那数据最好的肯定就是鬼呀。
因为全世界人民都怕鬼，都觉得人死了之后好像会变成鬼。
对吧你本来就有这个预期，本来就有这个担心。那鬼的数据当然好了。
所以他还是要符合观众的预期的，懂吧？
你看啊。
我们说有没有人开创这种预期呢？
当然有。
我们说斯皮尔伯格就开了好几回。
斯皮尔伯格拍过大白鲨。
我跟你说，在大白鲨之前，我们其实并没有太害怕鲨鱼。
鲨鱼在大白鲨这个电影出来之前不是一个负面形象，它就是一个很普通的鱼。
因为从数据显示啊。
就是。
攻击人类的动物啊，鲨鱼根本排不上号，搞不好排的比牛和马都低，就牛和马每年杀死的人搞不好，都比鲨鱼多。
每年也就是。
不到三位数鲨鱼。
因为确实他攻击人的情况很少，明白这个道理吧？但是他一旦攻击人就会上新闻头条，为什么呢？就拜大白鲨所赐，因为大白鲨这个电影实在影响力太大，造成了所有人上了海上之后都莫名其妙的感觉下面有一头鲨鱼要咬你。你看这就是开创者。
当然了，他也利用的是人类的一种集体。
我们说人类对深海深空是有。
是有天然恐惧的。然后呢，他利用这种天然恐惧，然后。
造了一个大白鲨。
给鲨鱼坑的可不轻了，是吧？但是这种事情也只有斯皮尔伯格这种级别的大师，他才敢做。也就是说他可以开新板子，从那以后你就可以开始拍鲨鱼怪兽了。在那之前谁也不敢拍，为什么？我们不害怕鲨鱼。
你明白吧？就像你今天拍一个暴走金鱼，恐怕就不行。暴走小金鱼，那这玩意儿那谁害怕呀，对吧？他能怎样呢？你就不要开这种。
新地图。
我跟你说，恐龙也是斯皮尔伯格开的呀。
侏罗纪公园就是斯皮尔伯格开的板子。
他为什么改干在那之前也没有人害怕恐龙，明白吧？因为我们都没见过恐龙，我们害怕个屁呀。
但是为什么斯比尔伯格在那个时间点敢。
开。
恐龙复活，然后杀人咬人这种片子呢，把恐龙塑造成一种人类共同的恐惧呢。
是因为当时的新闻。
出现了DNA技术。
就是。
人类似乎可以根据一个细胞造出一个动物了，这也就是克隆羊的那个年代。
前期。
然后这种苗条出来了，然后有人就提出来是不是可以复活一个恐龙的斯皮尔伯格马上嗅觉就到位了。
就拍了侏乐纪公园。
又污名化了一种动物，坑完鲨鱼，坑恐龙，大师就可以这么做，对吧？但我们呢觉得跟在大师的后面，你看在那之后，很多人就开始拍恐龙了。
对吧明白这个道理吧？
也就是说。
这种。
对手类的。
也必须是基于现有的大家的一个共同的预期或者共同集体潜意识里面的一个预期。好吧，这是一个注意事项。
我们说时间类的呢。
实践类的呢，我们说类型也就那么些了。
定在那儿不动的往前穿的，回到未来的对吧？去去到过去的。然后这个这个我说我们说回到未来开创者也是斯皮尔伯格。
你看斯皮尔伯格呀、詹姆斯卡梅隆呀，这种人都是开地图的人啊，他们都是开心类型的人。
我们就跟在后面就可以了。
然后嗯还有什么啊？
这个这个这个。
这个这个。
困在原地不动的对吧？土拨鼠日嗯，这这也是开地图的，后面就出了很多了。然后还有这种。
长生不老的，我觉得开地图的人应该很久远很久远之前了。因为这个愿望似乎是。
人类想要长生不老，至少从秦始皇就开始琢磨这个事了。所以这个地图应该是古人开的对吧？然后穿越题材不知道谁开的对吧？然后这个嗯。
反正就这种类型嘛，对吧？它都是基于人类共同的一种想象或者共同的一种期待，共同的一种担忧而产生的。但是还我还是那句话啊，你在这个类型下还是可以做创新的。
就像我说你看游戏类的片子有那么多。
但由于游戏跟雪国列车跟大逃杀，它就不是完全一样嘛，对不对？
来，我们说这种穿越类的，我们说那个蝴蝶效应就非常严重，值得大家去看一看。好吧，这节课会推荐很多参考片啊，大家可以最近又有片子看了啊，那个butterfly大家去看一看，好吧，那个就在穿越片里面就拍的相当好，相当的有。
局部创新吧，对吧？大规则我不去开心，不用开新地图，我就在穿越里面拍出我自己的特色。
大家也去研究一下，好吧，抱着学习的心态啊。
然后最后再说说回游戏类，我们说这种游戏类也是这种情况。我们说大规则其实差不多的。我刚才说了一个空间，然后参与人规则，然后奖励惩罚大规则差不多的。但为什么每次人家都能拍出新的东西呢？创新在哪里，创新就在这个规则。
创新就在这个规则。当然了，也有这些参与者的互相身份转换，对吧？你原本是个装，你其实原来伪装成一个玩家，或者是你完原本原本是个玩家，成长为成了一个装屠龙屠龙者终成恶龙，还是怎么着？这些当然还有细节上的创新。
好吧。
这节课呢主要就是给大家讲一下这种高设定。我们以前其实就管它叫高定，你知道吧？高设定。然后那个那个那个其实就是一种魔幻现实主义的一种选材。这种片子呢怎么玩？
大家大概明白了，首先分类就是这些分类，然后呢，玩法呢。
基本上就是基于前人已经开创的这些类型，然后在里面做局部创新。
这个不算抄袭啊，同学们，那你说由于游戏抄没抄雪之雪国列车，抄没抄我们中国人拍的动物世界呢？他妈差不多就是玩游戏输了死赢了赢钱，对吧？
这种类型啊，我们说它就是有人已经开创了这个大类了。
那你说这个这个这个这什么你好，李焕英，那跟那个早年的港片难兄难弟，那是相当像啊，对吧？梁朝伟和梁家辉那个嘛。
我们说其实这种穿越大类啊也都差不多。我们说那跟那个夏洛特烦恼不也挺像的，实际上都差不多啊就是。
我我的建议啊就是强舌定的片子，我们首先研究一下各种分类，研究一下各种分类里面的代表作，然后力求在这种分类下找到它的特点，然后做出自己的创新。这肯定是这种思路。当然了，你有雄才大略。你说我就想做斯皮尔伯格，我要开地图。
开板子也可以也可以。但是你要记住啊，你所谓的开的这个新的规则，新的东西一定要基于现实，是一种比喻，明白吧？否则的话，那就就就属于。
天马行空的异想天开了，对吧？我我们也可以去看一下刘慈欣的各种小说啊，他刘慈欣的想象力，这个是这是全球公认的牛逼，对吧？他也开创了很多呃好玩的规则。
但是呢也都是基于社会的比喻，大部分也都是基于什么阶层呀、贫富呀，对吧？种族隔阂呀、民族隔阂呀，基本上都是还是基于这种社会原有的一些规则去进行放大或者进行夸张比喻。
主要是进行比喻。
嗯。
但是话说回来，我也不是说强设定就就就天下无敌了，对吧？你你你现实主义设定还是有很多。
优势的呀，那现实主义设定我们说首先他如果拍剧的话，那。
他一旦呃那个站住脚了，他他可以拍很多季，知吧？乡村爱情吧？拍始拍拍了十多季了吧，搞不你不在了，他都在是吧？乡村爱情这种那就拍很多季啊，对吧？现实主义，你看那种技术长了都是现实主义题材啊，凡是技术长了都是现实主义题材。
啊，现实主义题实他有自己的优势啊呃他因为它真实嘛，它真实他入戏相对好入，你会觉得这是我们身边确实会发生的事情，很亲切，共情可以更到位。现实主义。那我们就说一下吧啊，来现实主义，我们说现实主义来现实主义它这种故事咋找呢？我们说我们。
强设定我们已经会了，对吧？强设定我们说大概分这么多类型，那我们在每种类型里面，我们自己琢磨琢磨规则，我们其实就可以搞出一个强设定。
世界观的一个。
这么一个选材选题，对吧？然后我们说那现实主义一般是什么选题呢？现实主义啊我觉得啊有有这么几种方法。首先，现实主义选题啊很多是基于新闻素材。
因为现实主义选题啊，你自己生活中能逮到一个好的选题，这种几率就比较小了。就你自己生活能经历到一个，那就比较小了，亲身经历到一个。
所以你看像药神呀这种都是基于。
新闻素材。
真人真事对吧？进行进行进行选材，这是一种。
常见的这个这个这个现实主义的一种选材方式。然后再有呢，其实就是素材浓缩或者叫生活的浓缩。
就是你把很多人经历的事情啊缩在一块儿。
这样的话也能形成一个带有，比如说它带有巧合。
带有巧合的。
我们说很多时候过去讲说无巧不成书啊。
故事得有点巧合，否则你这个故事讲它干嘛，对吧？你说我今天给你讲一个故事啊，就是我周末回家吃饭，我妈给我炒烧了三菜一汤，然后我们吃完饭睡觉了。
这是个事儿，但不是个故事呀，对吧？它没有巧合呀。
没有巧合呀。
所以说。
把生活进行一下浓缩，有时候也会产生一个现实主义题材的故事。比如说我们说失之一合，人就阿布宽周末回家吃饭这么一个故事，他也是要浓缩了很多世间，对吧？浓缩了。
离婚。
浓缩了孩子的。
呃，学费问题浓缩了。
老妈妈生病了，对吧？浓缩了各种各样的事情。
把很多事情浓缩在一起，形成一定程度的巧合，它就可以是一个相对现实主义的题材，对吧？我们说来我们再说个片子，比如说疯狂的石头吧。
疯狂的时候，他其实是一个现实主义选材嘛，这个事情不太魔幻吧。
并不算很魔幻嘛，还算相对现实吧，就是一个一个一个一个老工地老工厂挖出来一个这个老坑翡翠很值钱。然后呢，导致各方笨贼傻贼、牛逼贼都来惦记。然后还有那家贼难防也来惦记，都想来偷这块石头。然后这群人呢机缘巧合，全都。
穿在了一起，互相坑害，坏人自己自己跟自己打架，对吧？其实不就是浓缩一下，然后巧合一下嘛。所以说现实主义题材啊，它往往是就是。
这么玩的。
也还有它的市场啊，我们不要去否定它啊，喜欢现实主义题材的同学啊，不用不用不需要去去懊悔，或者是担心啊，现实主义题材依然有有它的市场。而且啊我再说一句话啊。
现实主义题材和魔幻现实主义题材啊，它的边界呀也没有分的那么清楚。
没有分的那么清楚。比如说我给大家举个例子啊。
西红柿首富。
哎，我们麻花的片子啊大部分是强设定，你发现了没有？麻花为什么这几年崛起了？
因为啊强设定的片子就是这几年才崛起的，以前没有人弄啊。
以前你敢想说我在大荧幕上弄一个穿越电影，人家觉得你跟闹着玩似的，你知道吗？穿越电影是B级片啊。
小众的闹着玩的花不了几个钱的。但确实夏洛特烦恼就是个BG片啊，就是没花多少钱呀，羞羞的铁拳也就是一个BG片啊，但是人家不就逆袭了嘛，对吧？达到了A级片的体量嘛？
所以你看。
麻花的片子啊大部分是抢设定。
魔幻现实主义。
但是我们说啊。
西红市首富啊。
你说他是现实主义还是磨坏现实主义，其实都可以。
来一个人突然继承了2亿。
现实吗？
也有。
有这种情况，你家里有个亲戚有20亿，然后他也没有别人，你算是雪原最近的叫20亿给你了。
可以说是现实主义题材。
但是呢你又要在多少天内花完，你看这就魔幻了。
它就相当于一个游戏啊。
他给你一个钱，然后他做庄，你当玩家，给你制定一个规则，有明确的奖励和惩罚。
他又是游戏类，这就魔幻了。
所以你看啊这个片子哎。
他其实两边踩。
所以说啥意思啊？就是现实主义跟魔幻现实主义啊，在有些片子里面啊分的也没有那么开。咱们话再说回来，由于游戏当然是魔幻现实主义。但是啊我们说会不会真的有人这么干。
我跟你说，有钱人真的有钱到一定程度，变态到一定程度，搞不好真他妈抓一群流浪汉去互相厮杀了。
说不定有呢。
是吧没法说呀。
再给大家说一个。
刚才我给大家还讲过一个片子，是一个剧叫疑犯追踪。
大家回去看一看啊，这个剧非常好看啊。
在这个这个这个呃。
这种类型的片子里面啊，在这个这个这个这这这算什么片子啊，算那个那个算算算刑侦类的片子吧啊。
呃，排名非常高啊，在美剧里面排第一的。
这片呢大家可以看一看。
我们说这个片子啊。
在刚出来的时候啊，他是一个魔幻现实主义。
他讲啊有一种网叫天网连接所有的摄像头，连接所有的电脑，连接所有的数据，连接所有的网络。
然后呢，能够洞悉每个人生活的一切。
能够知道你生活一切的细节，你的消费偏好，你的行为偏好，你的起你的饮食、起居，所有的细节他全都能掌握。
这个东西叫天网，然后他由此可以判断出你的犯罪倾向，你会不会犯罪，你什么时候犯罪？
这个东西刚出来的时候叫魔幻现实主义的一个设定。所以这个剧呢当时让人眼前一亮，是吧？因为它是基于对现社会的一种比喻，大家感觉这种技术似乎是可以的。
社会的一种比喻嘛？
然后大家就很爱看。
但是拍着拍着，这种技术现在其实实现了，你知道吗？
大数据现在已经完全实现这个。
都洗了。
所以其实他现在又成了了一个现实主义的片子了，我感觉。
你看这也是这个片子为什么长寿这个片子也拍了十际了吧。
十几G了。
一个魔幻现实主义的片子如何这么持久呢？因为它变成现实主义了。
随着这几年科技的发现，发展，他这个所谓的天网就是现在的大数据嘛。
已经实现了。
对吧所以我说这些什么意思啊？就是所谓的现实主义跟魔幻现实主义啊，界限没有那么明确，有些片子就卡在当中的。
懂吧？所以。
你喜欢写现实主义，接着写没问题。好吧，这节课呢其实就想通过游鱼游序游鱼游戏这个片子着重的给大家讲一讲强设力。
可以是主角有什么能力呀、超能力呀，或者是你的对手呀，特别可怕呀，对吧？是是是是是外来生物呀，或者是鬼呀，是怪兽啊，或者是你的时间上揉搓呀，时间静止了呀，时间倒流了呀，穿越了呀，肉体交换了呀，是吧？灵魂转移了呀。
然后呢或者就是游戏类把一群人关起来做一个什么样的游戏呀？
这个这个我跟你说，其实黄渤那个也严格说也算魔幻现实主义，他那个大家困在一个岛上做游戏，当然是生存游戏啊，当然很残酷啊。但是因为审查的原因，他那个好像不怎么死人，对吧？死人死太少了，那就没意思了。所以他那个片子就这个劲儿太小了，你知道吗？奖励和惩罚劲儿太小了。
然后我们说这种片子你也会知道。
该怎么玩好吧，就这节课主要就想跟大家讲一下强设力。我们通过由鱼游戏学一下强设力。
那么。
这些咱们之前基本上都做过一些训练了啊，我给大家讲过，你拥有什么样的技能，或者是你这个这个穿越了。我们说经常我还给你出过题，你穿越了只能带一样东西，你带啥是吧？这个这个我们说穿越啊往往是这样啊，你看穿越类的片子啊。
往往有两种趋势，一种趋势呢就是强人穿越。你看我为什么反复强调啊，我们今天讲的这种设定方法，其实是世界观的一种设定方法，并不是你的故事类型，是你的故事选材。
对吧因为。
假设啊比如说来你的对手是个鬼，我们说你这个片子里面有鬼。
有外星人或者有神秘力量，有鬼，但是你的故事类型还是可以有各种类型啊。你和这个鬼是好伙伴，那你就是伙伴之情啊，有啊。
变形金刚。
变形金刚大黄蜂不就是外来神力力量吗？他不就相当于一个鬼吗？你和他不就是伙伴吗？
你们俩不就是伙伴之情吗？男主跟变那个那个那个大大黄蜂就是伙伴之情呀，变形金刚一对吧？然后我们说来鬼片来了，来鬼了。
那个那个那个那个鬼屋。
是很常见的嘛，然后还有什么小人物出大事，还有像毒液这种来了鬼了，你变牛逼了。
对吧你成超级英雄了。
所以说故事类型啊。
是另外一个维度的分法。我们今天讲的是选材类型，对吧？选材类型。
我们说穿越类的啊穿越类的，你看啊也有两种故事走向，一种是强人穿越。
项少龙他本身就是个特警。
然后他穿越回秦朝，当了一个大将军。你看你对这种片子的期待就是那他去了肯定大展拳脚啊。
他既有智商，对吧？又有组织能力，而且还有现代化的作战思维。
还有物理搏斗的能力。
你看他去了之后肯定大展拳脚呀。
大量成。
这种就是鱼。
那个那个往上的期待，还有往下的担忧呢，太子飞升之际，一个大老爷们儿穿越了古代，穿越到古代一个妃子的身体里面。那皇帝还要睡他了呀，他如何能够应对对吧？他如何能够在这这个残酷的宫斗中生存下去。
你替他很担心啊，因为他完全不适应呀。
对吧就就是就是穿越类，你如果想写穿越类，你也要了解，你得往这两个方向使劲儿，你要么让观众特别期待，要么让观众特别担忧。
水平转移。
就别搞了，那你穿越过去干嘛？
对吧你说我在我在现实生活中，我在超市当营业员。
然后穿越到古代呢，在一个菜市场卖菜，那你去干嘛呀？
你在原始工作岗位就能把这个事办了呀，还穿入去干嘛呀？明白这个道理吧？没有意思，好吧。
所以这你看每一种类型啊都有自己的要点。那我们说回今天我们的作业为大家布置个作业，我们就借游鱼游戏这个这个这个这个这这个片子，我们就做一个自己的。
由于游戏。
你设计一个。
空间。
然后一群参与者，然后呢，他们呢。
被制定了一个规则，这个规则在这个规则玩法下有奖励和惩罚。
着重要设计的当然是首先设计这个规则，因为这个规则需要是社会规则的比喻。
你可以比喻最常见的阶层。
贫富差距。
当然也可以比喻呃民族隔阂、种族冲突。
这个这个这个。
教育体制是吧，或者是还有什么。
你自己想吧，好吧，你比喻某个东西。
然后嘞。
给我构建一个提案，构建一个方案，好吧，这个这个是这节课的作业。
嗯，差不多到时间了啊。
但是说到作业啊，我得给。
我多说几句啊，跟同学们啊。
就是因为我之前也布置过作业。
然后有一次吧一个同学写了一个作业之后呢，我就。
我其实没有办法，每个同学的作业都看啊，因为咱们同学太多了，但是有一些同学跟我。
就是联系比较多或者是比较早期的学员呢，他的作业我会看。
有一次我印象特别深刻，就一个同学写了一个作业啊。
给我看问我老师写的好不好，反正问我嘛，我说还行啊，有点意思。
然后呢，他就说那我还需要在。
有什么改进吗？我说你这里啊最好再补一补某种对吧？冲突，我说这里可能差点意思。
然后这个同学就很积极。
第二天就发给我了。
第二天就发给我了，就是他补了补了点东西，第二天就发给我了。
把作业给我了。
然后我就我就把这茬给忘了，对吧？这这事儿给忘了。然后过了一段时间啊，这个同学突然发信息给我。
上来第一句话就给我整懵了。
孙老师。
我那个戏啥时候拍？
然后我说啊。
啥戏呀？
他说我上次写的那个呀。
我一下想起来了，我说啊。
我说那个。
那个没说要拍呀。
说啊。
我那天晚上写到两点多啊。
我说那写到两点多，他一共也就3000字呀。
咋拍呀？你。
他说不拍我写他干嘛，我都跟我妈说了。
我说你妈不会已经在家守着中央一套在那等着了吧。
就咱们有些同学啊，因为是网上的同学，我见不到真人，你知道吗？我不太了解每个同学他所处的环境，他的。
他的背景或者是他的理解。
就有些同学就以为我夸，可能就我嘴贱，我就不该夸，你明白我意思吧？我就不该夸，，有点意思。我说了之后，他就以为要拍了。
然后接下来更离谱，我说这这个他就跟我说，那我写到两点多啊，写了几千字，他就要拍了，你明白吧？然后后来更离谱，然后我就说这是练习嘛，哪有这个这个这个这这这再说这几千字咋拍啊？然后他就问我说，他说那。
要不老师，你把这个剧本收了吧。
然后我就说那收了是啥意思啊？是让我出钱吗？
然后说你要多少钱？
他说要300万。
他说他晚上起到两点多，累死了要300万。
哎呦，我的妈呀。
老师，我熬一个夜，熬到两点多也卖不了300万啊，同学们啊。
这个。
哎，当然这位同学没有恶意啊，他只是可能对这个圈子挣钱的速度。
可能受了郑爽的影响啊，受了那些数据的影响啊。
就是他没有恶意。
是这样啊，就是同学们写的东西，我平常给大家布置的作业啊都是练习级别的，就是他。
大家认真练认真写。
对美好的未来可以有想象。但是呢你不要老想着挣我的钱呀，是不是你想挣300万，你往外面挣去嘛，对吧？不要老我那天还跟班委会说，我说哎，为什么因为之前还有一个同学啊，我说我们现在同学多了啊，真的是形形色色的人都有，还有一个同学啊也是问我要几百万。
让我投资他的项目。
投资他的这个这个这个这个剧本。
我且得账口有好几百万。
然后我我那天都在反思这个问题。
我是说我是做了什么？
我是很浮夸吗？
如何让。
有些同学认为我很有钱。
可以到处投资，可以几百万往外撒，是我是做了什么？让。
同学们产生了这样的误解呢，我也没有浮夸到那个程度吧，是吧？
然后呢，后来我们班委会的同学就给我提醒我说，你可能啊就是因为你在课上啊说你年轻的时候资助小孩读书一个月1万块钱。
我说我一个月1万块钱资助小朋友读书，这是实实情。但我那时候一个月也就挣2万多呀。
我并不是说能挣100万，所以拿出一万资助小朋友读书。我说了，我当时二十四五岁不太懂事，所以一个月只挣2万多，我都拿出来1万去资助小朋友。为什么呢？因为那时候太单纯，你知道吧？不知道钱咋花呀，花钱的地方不多。
那时候连酒还都不会喝呢。
不知道钱咋花，你知道吧？
现在我肯定不会做这种蠢事了，拿出一半收入给别人对吧？而且那钱能不能到小朋友手里还两说呢？是不是？所以说大家不要误解啊，我呢就是一个很普通的一个。
不是富豪，也不会把钱到处往外撒，大家不要有这个误解啊，你们好好学习，从市场上挣钱，不要老惦。你看我现在发现同学们逐渐升级了，以前是白嫖白嫖课程，后来呢还想来混吃混住，对吧？我说过有些同学提出来说老师我到你身边。
跟你学习吧，你包吃包住就行了。我说哎怎么还要我包吃包住呢？现在又开始要钱了，这是怎么回事啊，是吧？
这个同学们千万不要这么想啊，这个我今天借这个机会澄清一下，因为今天又布置作业了，我怕很多同学写完之后，我说哎这写的不错，然后他就想卖给我，你知道吗？这个不行啊，这作业就是作业啊，这种就是练习级别的几千个字儿，你想卖给谁去啊。
明白吗？同学们好吧，大家这个这个认真的练习。这个通过由于游戏，我们讲的这个游戏类的这种。
这种这种选材它有些什么样的规则，大家试着去设计一个自己的游戏类题材的小故事，好吧。
我们之前做过穿越类的练习，做过这个超级英雄类的练习都做过啊，大家那个没做过的啊，也可以去琢磨琢磨。总之总结一下这节课，强设定的选材这几年是在走高的，我们不得不承认，对吧？因为它有它的优势，它有它的优势。
而且无论是电影还是剧。
都在走高。
但是现实主义题材我们。
还是要守住，还是要会写会玩，对吧？
他还是有它的魅力的吧，还是有它的魅力的。好吧，这节课先说这么多吧，大家别忘了做作业，下课吧。
嗯。